it's tough in these nets
where amateur cricket players practice
even in the off season
but if asian youngsters thought things
get better at the top
this week gave them a taste of what may
come at them i'm from yorkshire so
representing yorkshire would be a big
part of
a cricketing career but
yeah
now since that story has come out i find
it hard to really represent i feel like
all the other people from other
other backgrounds will be um considered
before before and i think that
we have to be much better for them
much better than other people to be
selected when you hear things like this
maybe
you know
yeah it gives you a wider view of
reality and say
you might not have the same
opportunities
the future of the country's cricket
talent lie in places like this
youngsters who live and breathe the
sport but allegations of racism at one
of england's most historic clubs have
left many doubting their chances
sky news has spoken to british asian
cricketers in all levels of the game who
say they're put off playing for
yorkshire none of them wanted to come on
camera because they say the industry as
a whole isn't the kind of place where
you can speak openly about your
experiences
it seems a long time ago that england's
diverse world cup winners helped boost
the game's profile with 10 000 more
fixtures played in adult recreational
cricket this year than when england
lifted that trophy
grassroots coaches say racism at
yorkshire looks set to unravel all that
it unlocks all the good work that we've
been doing for decades and it takes us
back
to an era where
racism was rife but we've been making so
much progress so this sort of incident
takes us back to that that unfortunate
era for yorkshire crickey remember it
was not that long ago where yorkshire
had a policy but unless you were born in
yorkshire you could play for yorkshire
whenever yorkshire play here at
headingley stadium they can count on a
big contingent of fans from an asian
background
but today they're expected to
demonstrate against the club in
solidarity with azeem rafiq
in these nets hours of practice are
meant to pay off but after this week's
revelations young players may need some
convincing
sadia chowdhury sky news in yorkshire